let's get now to mega world exploding
over the fbi raiding donald trump's
house they are throwing everything at
the wall to see what sticks they're all
going crazy they're doing emergency
podcasts they're saying this is going to
be the undoing of the republic it is a
dystopian hellscape it is over for the
united states because of the fbi raiding
donald trump let's look at some examples
these are great
here's mark levin
calling this one of the worst attacks on
the republic in modern history now you
keep asking your guests what's the
justification there is no justification
what's he going to say tomorrow the
attorney general here's my guess
we've been negotiating with trump and
his lawyers since february when we found
out they had this information we were
getting nowhere and then we know or we
heard that some documents were being
destroyed maggie hagerman of the new
york slimes
was on cnn they've been running pictures
of hers that she's going to have in the
book
of documents being flushed on a toilet
that doesn't mean a damn thing it could
be anything
phonics name on it that's all it was
okay but what i'm saying is you've asked
what would the pretext be
correct and so it is a pretext is
exactly right
there is no justification for sending 30
friggin fbi agents to the former
president's compound in mar-a-lago in
early morning and conducting themselves
this way or in any other cases in which
they've done exactly the same thing the
fbi is corrupt this guy garland goes
after parents he goes after republican
uh
state legislatures he goes after states
he disagrees with their abortion
positions he doesn't do a damn thing to
protect the border which is compelled by
the constitution nothing
so let's be clear
newt is right they're all right
this is the worst attack on this
republic in modern history so levin is
flipping out but the truth is this would
not have happened were there not
significant eyes dotted in t's crossed
next we go to newsmax guest bernie
carrick
not a guy unfamiliar with legal problems
and he said he's worried the next step
is they're going to assassinate donald
trump and i just put out a tweet about
this
if you remember back in 2016 when i when
right before he got elected i was in
washington dc i was at a couple
different social events and i hear
people talking they said the democrats
want this guy so bad
that they wouldn't put assassination
behind it
and and i'm going to tell you something
they've tried impeachment
they've tried another impeachment
they've tried one investigation after
another this is about one thing
this is about stopping him from running
in 2024
and i'm going to tell you something i'm
not into conspiracies i'm not into
anti-government rhetoric
this is the first time in my lifetime
that i would say i am deathly afraid for
donald trump i would not put
assassination
behind these people right
a raid based on probable cause a warrant
signed by a judge and everything done
properly could very clearly be a pretext
to assassinating donald trump here's
radical republican congresswoman lauren
bobert saying this is the gestapo guys
i'm pissed we are a nation of law and
order and this raid by the fbi on
president trump's home is totally
unamerican this is gestapo crap and it
will not stand well you know i don't
remember the gestapo regularly having
sworn affidavits court order signed by a
judge and all of it when they conducted
raids many such examples i think you
understand alex jones and roger stone
uh convening an emergency podcast over
the raid likening it to nazi germany
who's as a former political prisoner
himself and what he believes this means
roger stone thanks for joining us on
this emergency broadcast it's an
emergency alex it's a it's a very very
sad day for america this is the kind of
thing you expect to see in soviet russia
nazi germany communist cuba
they don't know how to handle this sean
hannity we covered this last night on
the live stream he spoke for about 11
minutes without taking a breath and here
is some of his dystopian outlook on what
took place first a dark day for our
republic the department of justice the
rule of law what looks to be potentially
a shocking overreach we'll find out in
due time that will have serious
ramifications
potentially for many many years to come
a lot of potentialities in there
potentially doing very very heavy
lifting for sean hannity marjorie taylor
green now says on twitter quote defund
the fbi
not exactly support the police
type
behavior by marjorie taylor green and
then lastly right wing bomb thrower dan
bongino saying that the left thinks this
is all hilarious
i just want to say in closing listen
america they're laughing at you the left
thinks this is hilarious if you doubt me
just go to any of their goofy platforms
twitter elsewhere right now they think
this is hilarious now i have to tell you
bongino is correct to a certain degree
i do think this is absolutely hilarious
but it also seems to be completely
appropriate based on the facts that we
have known for a very long time
no one that commits crimes against the
american people should feel safe and
there's a lot of people that commit
crimes and do feel safe because we have
a two-tier justice system we don't know
where this will go but we are going to
follow it and you've got to see eric
trump's reaction to all of this
the science has shown us that one of the
ways to achieve consistent deep sleep is
to lower your core body temperature at
night it also is just really
uncomfortable to be too hot when you're
trying to sleep our longtime sponsor
chili sleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that improve
your sleep by keeping you cool at night
chili sleeps cube and ooler sleep
systems are hydropowered mattress
toppers they fit on your existing
mattress and they provide the ideal
sleep temperature
you can keep your bed as cool as 55
degrees or as hot as 115. i like 62
personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
it's fantastic and chili sleep is the
only company on the market doing it like
this you'll get thirty percent off your
new cube or uhler sleep system at
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is down below